this is Monday October 31st and this is
the closer I'm Keith Olbermann Donald
Trump is for once correct it is worse
than Watergate and as in Watergate the
director of the FBI must resign first he
must retract his statement then resign
there are only two alternatives here
James B Comey either knowingly tried to
tamper with a presidential election 11
days out on a hint of a possibility of a
rumor of an inference of a chance of
Clinton emails that reportedly aren't
from Clinton and are to Clinton which
his bureau had not bothered to tell him
about nor gotten a warrant for until
last night or James B Comey had no idea
that his statement would impact a
presidential election in such a way that
there would not be a chance to disprove
the negative
he threw against the wall like the [ __ ]
by all accounts it is in the former case
Comey wants that rarest of individuals
the nonpartisan legal hero from the Bush
administration is a criminal who has
desperately and personally and at the
last minute tried to deliver this
country at its 240 years of democracy
into the hands of a self-obsessed
compulsively lying fascist with no
respect nor interest in anyone or
anything besides himself and no
understanding of the real world and the
billions of people he could kill in a
fit of pique over something somebody
would say about him on TV in the latter
case Comey is merely criminally stupid a
man who did not foresee that his actions
were the equivalent of crying fire in a
theater without saying which theater he
means and with no evidence that there is
any fire anywhere regardless of which
stupidity or criminality his viability
as the head of the FBI ended the moment
he sent his note last Friday to among
others the chairman of the United States
House of Representatives Committee on
Oversight and Government Reform who
should also resign today because this is
far worse than just an FBI director
swinging the mighty weight of his Bureau
against one presidential candidate while
refusing to confirm that the bureau is
even investigating the other
presidential candidate and his staff and
his former staff for its manifestly
obvious ties to Russian propaganda and
information far worse than that the
actions of the chairman of the United
States House of Representatives
Committee on Oversight and Government
Reform before and after director Comey's
letter imply either collusion or
guesswork on the Chairman's part that
rises to the level of extrasensory
perception because on Friday on Saturday
yesterday and even this morning the
timeline of how that chairman mr.
Chaffetz of Utah former wrinkle cream
spokesman came to know about the
investigation has been almost utterly
ignored and that timeline is at best
disturbing on the night of Friday
October 7th hours after the release of
the Access Hollywood tape of Donald
Trump boasting about his preferred
methods for sexual assault
representative Chaffetz spoke of his 15
year old daughter quote do you think I
can look her in the eye and tell her
that I endorsed Donald Trump for
president when he acts like this and his
apology that was no apology that was an
apology for getting caught so I'm not
going to put my good name and reputation
and my family behind Donald Trump for
president when he acts like this I just
can't do it the morality of chairman
Chaffetz lasted exactly 19 days at 9:05
p.m. Eastern Daylight Time last
Wednesday night 26th
mr. Chaffetz out of nowhere suddenly
tweeted again quote I will not defend or
endorse at real Donald Trump but I am
voting for him HRC is that bad HRC is
bad for the USA so much where mr.
Chaffetz his 15 year old daughter
sometime around noon last Friday mr.
Chaffetz received his communication from
FBI director Comey about a hint of a
possibility of a rumor of an inference
of a chance of Clinton emails that
aren't from Clinton and aren't to
Clinton which is Bureau hadn't bothered
to tell him about nor gotten a warrant
for until last night immediately after
receiving commis ode to vagueness
mr. Chaffetz put two essential critical
devastating words into mr. commis mouth
at 12:57 p.m. Eastern Daylight Time last
Friday the 28th 39 hours and 52 minutes
after he repudiated his own moral stance
and declared his support for this Trump
Chaffetz tweeted quote FBI director
Justin
for me quote the FBI has learned to the
existence of emails that appear to be
pertinent to the investigation unquote
case reopened that of course is not what
Comey said mr. Comey did not say he had
reopened the case of all the pernicious
anti FBI anti-american anti-democracy
things
James B Comey did last Friday and before
saying he had reopened the case was not
one of them jason Chaffetz said that and
that made it easy for people to think
that Comey had legally reopened this
case and then Donald Trump said that and
lied and then television with the
exception of my former colleague the
noble Pete Williams of NBC said that and
broadcast that lie and then newspapers
with almost no exceptions from left or
right said that and printed that lie and
by the time they started backtracking
the toothpaste was out of the tube
except that this was probably imaginary
toothpaste if we take director Comey at
his word he had no idea he still has no
idea his agents reportedly knew of the
emails at the beginning of October yet
he did not get a warrant until last
night he may not have the slightest idea
before the election and he has nothing
with which to undo his malfeasance or
misfeasance or betrayal of the
democratic process but ignore not
Chaffetz why after nearly three weeks of
righteous indignation Trump's barbarism
towards women indeed towards people why
late Wednesday night did he suddenly
pivot back to supporting Trump why did
he reverse 36 hours before commis
historically slovenly cravin note that
left Pandora's box unjustly unlocked so
that a sniveling little coward like
Chaffetz could peek inside then
deliberately exaggerate what he saw and
then fueled Donald Trump's latest
delusional rage most assuredly jason
Chaffetz is a prophet worthy of his
religions Joseph Smith or he is the
recipient of an accident of timing so
unlikely as to be almost biblical or he
knew or suspected he knew that commis
note was coming however would he have
found
about that FBI agents who reportedly
knew an FBI director who was reportedly
suddenly terrified of leaks and it
chafed its new commis note was coming
then he and Comey or other sources in
the FBI have colluded to try to
manipulate the election in which case
mr. Chaffetz and mr. Comey may need the
best criminal defense attorneys money
may procure and if Chaffetz knew commis
note was coming did he also tell Trump
and who can clear this up a week in a
day before the most important election
since the Civil War on that
fifteen-year-old daughter mr. Chaffetz
isn't so worried about anymore
she has far more to worry about right
now than listening to the psychopaths
Trump boast about grabbing [ __ ]
because she may soon be looking for a
paternity test to prove jason Chaffetz
is not her father
because he and James Comey may have been
the linchpins in a plot to turn over
this country by treachery to Donald
Trump and it is a plot that is indeed as
Trump boasted worse than Watergate
that's the closer on Keith Olbermann
watch this space